now to a very different kind of story an
update to A Magical Tale we first shared
last month you may remember this letter
written by Madeline who just turned
seven she asked Los Angeles County
Department of animal care and control
for approval to keep a unicorn in her
backyard in response the department
issued its first ever unicorn license
this is true lead National correspondent
David begno visited the family whose
name we're keeping private and learned
how Madeline's love of unicorns is
taking her on a journey far from home
I love them
here's my room
enter Madeline's world and you come
under the mystical spell of a mythical
creature what is it that makes unicorns
so special that their magical horn
it grants you magic wishes if you ask
yeah double rainbows in the sky magic
purple butterflies at seven years old
she is obsessed with unicorns they live
in the magical forest of Scotland
that fictional Beast so beloved and
popular is the real national animal of
Scotland in Celtic mythology it is a
symbol of Purity innocence and Power
and have you been to Scotland no so
what's the plan to get your unicorn well
I'm going to take a airplane okay and
then I'm going to find the unicorn in
the magical forest and bring it back on
the airplane
Madeleine has been smitten with the
Unicorn since she was three years old
and can tell you anything you want to
know and what else is involved in taking
care of it
making sure it sees rainbows sunlight
and mood beams so I'm going to make the
barn have a glass roof back in November
Madeline told her mom Leilani that she
wanted a real unicorn so Mom suggested
that Madeline learn the rules about
owning a large animal by writing to the
Los Angeles County Department of animal
care and control I would like permission
if I could have a unicorn in my backyard
if I could find one now Mom there are
things over the course of our life that
we explore and come to understand what's
your intention sort of behind going
through the process with Madeline well
Madeleine's a very curious little girl
anything that she proposes we want to
encourage and support so when she came
up to me with this idea I thought okay
we can do this but let's do it through
the proper measures of seeing what's
required to maintain such a large animal
enter Marcia mayetta the director of
Animal Care and Control for LA County
she got Madeline's letter and she wrote
her back the first requirement
is that she'd comply with all County
regulations by keeping animals that she
had to feed the Unicorn watermelon at
least once a week because that's their
favorite trait she had to polish the
unicorn's horn at least once a month
with a soft cloth and any Sparkles or
glitter used on the Unicorn must be
non-toxic and biodegradable of course
well after agreeing to follow those
rules Madeleine visited the Animal Care
Center on her seventh birthday to get
her unicorn license the first ever issue
by L.A County it is bigger than me I
think the takeaway for parents is to
support your children's dreams you know
don't stifle them I think it's really
important that adults do that
when L.A County shared Madeleine's story
on social media it went viral touching
Hearts around the world I would just
like to thank you for reducing me to a
blubbering weeping mess when I read
about your beautiful piece of kindness
to Madeline I'm a six foot two hundred
and forty pound piece of British meat
who has seen his fair share of savagery
and nastiness in the world animals and
humans alike should be grateful as you
make the world a better place we're just
kind of riding on that wave of Joy
while our fascination with the Unicorn
goes back to ancient times they are as
popular as ever today
and what's the takeaway for everybody
who felt something from this story that
there's really still a lot of that
innocence and just pure joy still out
there and it's a lot of fun to follow
we'll get a book to read to you after
all a child's imagination is boundless I
either I've learned
if you want something then you have to
ask for it and to ask for you have to do
something to ask for it I love it
David joins us now David there's a look
that you get in certain interviews where
you just know something beautiful is
happening right in front of you and this
is one of those like she believes in
Magic and I support that yes it's so
real mom was saying listen when she came
and she said I want a unicorn she said
well you got to go figure out how to
take care of it and so about 10 minutes
later she's like okay well here's the
letter what are we doing and she was
like uh well we're gonna figure out
where to send it now right
with that kind of encouragement that you
can achieve your dreams you just have to
figure out the steps and the hard work
to get there 100 and you know kids have
a way of softening the hearts of adults
that's right and I think that's what
this story does uh but I should tell you
that the foundation for L.A County
Animal Care and Control set up
Madeleine's magical unicorn fun so if
there happens to be a 25 donation they
are ready to issue more unicorn permits
I thought you'd like to know that oh I
think more permits are coming soon David
I don't know I'll be there yeah I can't
wait for the follow-up I hope she finds
it I hope she finds one I believe in
magic I believe in her we all do she's
planning the trip to Scotland now that's
awesome David as usual thank you